hola I hereby declare I can't see a
thing a second ah much better
I hereby declare a moratorium on movies
about real people who decide to become
superheroes look the point of special
super Defendor and kick ass and now kick
ass too is plain cosplay vigilantes are
out of place in drab mundane everyday
reality people behind these films seem
to think they're making some grander
point
oh he's wearing a costume and fighting
crime but punch his brake bones and hurt
real bad because that's how it works in
real life get it get it
well no felder carbs
starbuck the writers these films think
that there are actually sad deluded
individuals out there who can't see the
disconnect between our reality and
comic-book reality what why are you
looking at me like that me I have no
problem
distinguishing between comic-book
reality and our reality our own realm
known as earth-616 or earth prime
depending on your preferred comic-book
theology I make no judgment is one
universe among many no one on our
version of Earth has superpowers
that we know of at present and no one
has invented a transdimensional warp to
let us access these alternate Earth's
with superheroes yet but I guess
ultimately movies like kick-ass don't
make sense to me because big budget
blockbusters are themselves a parallel
universe where digital color correction
and CG effects and two-dimensional
characters make it better suited to
telling superhero stories than depicting
everyday reality I call this parallel
realm Planet Hollywood
oh wait that second I call this parallel
realm earth squared hmm thanks for
watching please leave your comments
below